[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la petite marguerite
esté singulière du brevvière de la baie
trois pétales le scandale sur l'hôutel
indiscrète paquerette d'où vient-elle
trois pétal de scandale sur l'haôtel
dans l'enceinte sacro sainte qu et moi
quelle affaire oui ma chère
croyez-moi la frivole fleur qui vole
arrivant contrebande desplatementand de
du
couvant la frivole fleur qui vole
arrivant contrebande des plates bande du
couvant notre Père qui j'espère être
auciieux n'ayez cure des murmures
malicieux la légère fleur pe chère ne
vient pas de nettees de cornettes en
sabat la légère fleur pe chère ne vient
pas de nonnette de cornettes en
sabat sachez dientre qu'un jour entre
deux avé sur la pierre d'un calvaire il
a trouvé et la mise chose admise par le
ciel sans embage dans les pages du
missel et et la mise chose admise par le
ciel sans embage dans les pages du Mel
que ces mess basse C jeu vous prie non
le prêtre n'est pas traître à Marie que
personne ne soupçonne plus jamais la
petite marguerite à sa mainre que
petite marguerite à sa
[Musique]
main